(Dr. Who music)
- Everything, everything
is great about Doctor Who.
- In England, you have the
people, like their grandparents
watched it, their parents
watch it, now they watch it.
- I love that no matter
what you like or what you're
interested in, there's a Doctor
for you or a time period,
or a story, or a companion.
- And it's just, you know, it's escapism,
it's a different world.
- The fourth doctor is
so cool, and he would
just whip these out to make
friends with his enemies.
- They don't look like babies.
- The fourth doctor picks orange,
so I'm going to pick orange.
- Mmmm.
- They're squishy on the inside.
- Very chalky.
- It tastes mediciney.
- This powder is making me want to cough.
- I'd totally Tom Baker
these jelly babies up.
- [man and woman] Jammie Dodgers!
- It's the TARDIS self-destruct button!
- Oh man, Matt Smith, he's my man,
he was my first doctor.
- These better taste as good as they look.
- If it was really a
Doctor Who food, though,
it would have two hearts.
- Not crazy about 'em.
- I could see how they taste
better with a fez on, though.
- Um hm, or two.
- I like it, it's not too sweet.
- This is nice and
chewable, and yum-tastic.
- This is what I told you in there!
Fish fingers and custard! (screams)
- This looks nasty.
- Is it weird that I'm gonna cry?
- Well, it was like the only
thing he found palatable
after his regeneration.
So, I'm assuming it's not going to be
that strong of a flavor.
- I'm a little afraid,
I'm not a fish person.
- I do like fish fingers,
I do like custard.
- I'm so happy right now.
Mm, I'm less happy now.
- Mmm.
- Wow, that's strangely satisfying.
- Custard's not good, you guys.
- You definitely had to have
just regenerated to want this.
- Oh my gosh! (laughter)
- Adipose!
- Oh my gosh!
- This is one of my
favorite episodes, too.
- It's perfect that these are a snack,
because when you see them in the show you
just want to eat them up because
they're so cute and fluffy.
- They should have just eaten
the adipose when they came
out of their body; that would have solved
the whole problem, right?
- Are they gonna burst
out of me if I eat this,
like in the show?
- Yeah, go ahead, have a
little chubby little arm.
- Mm, who knew fat could be so tasty?
- Everything's dusted with space-time.
- Rip 'em apart, woo.
- The fat just walks away.
- Jammie Dodger, Adipose s'mores.
- Trying the food from the show
is like getting a whole, new
experience that the TV
show just can't do for you.
- I feel closer to the Doctor now.
(Dr. Who music)